Julian, right? Julian? Julian.
Yes. You got it. Yes. You're you.
You're the one that loves to sing. So big
question. What is your ideal first date?
We, I don't think I'm the
one that actually he likes
the same but that's okay.
Oh Gosh. Oh, so sorry.
How do you think you get to know someone
without actually seeing them in person?
If it's through a conversation over
a phone, then you get to know them.
That's why I really love telemarketers
when they give me a call because then we
can jive and have a great
conversation from there. But two,
when it comes to photos,
you just swipe to see who you
think is the most attractive.
And I don't think that's necessarily
the best way to get to know someone.
But
yeah.
Hello, how are you? I'm good.
How are you? Life is a beautiful,
what's your name? And uh, do you
have any siblings? Hey, yeah,
my name is Liz and I actually have
three younger siblings. Nice. Yes. Hi,
I'm Victoria.
I have two younger siblings that are
eight and 10 years apart from me.
And I liked to play tennis.
I'm Sabrina,
but people call me Sabz but with like
a Z. Oh yeah. But you know different.
I want to be different. Most of my days
I do jumping jacks sort of how you, hi,
my name is Diana and I love food.
And what do you mean by you do
jumping jacks favor on this week?
This week in and out? I don't
know the secret menu protein.
Burger. Lettuce. Yeah. Hello.
My name is Jonathan and I love singing
in the shower. Are you a shower person?
I am a shy person. Are you morning
or night? Quick morning shower. Yeah.
I'm a morning shower person too. And
then my name is [inaudible]. By the way,
being Hispanic, I'm Hispanic.
There's a lot of me.
It's hard to be vegetarian in both
of our cultures. I'm Kiana like,
well all my friends call me
key. So I like that. Yeah,
I remember like key to your heart.
That's like basically how you're
gonna remember me above. Oh,
I love how you said
that. Kiana. I love food.
I've told her brothers who
they like individuals that
are men that walk into the
place where they want to ask
you out on a date. I mean,
they don't get involved in my business.
We're really distant.
Are you close with their siblings?
Super close.
That's why I'm kind of like a child,
but also mature at the same time,
but mostly a child.
Oh Gosh. I feel really bad. Um,
I'm going to do, uh, Courtney.
I was
unable to really get to know
her right away. And then Coco,
you know,
I've dated people before that had rough
siblings and that usually didn't turn
out right. So, uh, those
are the two reasons why,
um, ideal first date. Um, I
like things really super chill.
So going to a coffee shop, going on
a hike and I love hiking. That's,
that's exactly what I love too.
Yeah.
Well my favorite is we start off with
something small. Like a hike. Yes.
And then if it's cooler than
that, then it's like, oh,
do you want to do an activity like rock
climbing? Wait, I climbed till God,
you were joking. I really like
the beach. I love the water so,
and I haven't been in awhile,
so I think that would be really cool.
I think the best part of
the day is just to talk.
So I really liked seeing places.
I like walking around somewhere.
So I do love art museums.
Do you like single dates or let's say
there's like a group setting of the day.
Ooh, I've never done like a group
day. I've never done a double date.
So that could be something fun to
experience. Okay. Alright, Julian, right?
Julian? Julian? Yeah. You got
it. Yes. You're you. You're
the one that loves to sing.
So big question. What is
your ideal first date? Yeah.
I don't think I'm the one that actually
likes the same, but that's okay. Oh Gosh.
Oh, so sorry. Okay. My I do first day.
I would love to do
something where we can talk,
but also where we're doing something
kind of active like mini golfing or
bullying,
I think anything food related I love
like anything like Greek or anything.
Did you know you live longer if you
eat Mediterranean food? So they say,
we really, sorry, I didn't.
So you're going to be able to
like live all very long life.
Anything outdoorsy is pretty
much really like my ideal date.
Sounds like a lot of fun
to do. That sounds fun. Um,
that's cool.
Wait, you're a vocal director. Do
you have law students as well? Yeah.
So you're a teacher teaching.
Okay. All right. Bye.
Okay.
Oh, they're, they're all really great.
I am. Okay. So the first one, yeah,
kick me out and I apologize again.
Is Brianna the energy?
I guess it's just different. That's
it. We're just two different energies.
I like Mclean. I like, uh, like chill.
Yana
I hope I, I hope I have picked
the right one. I, oh gosh.
Okay.
Liz, what is your deal breaker
when it comes to dating?
I think it's about extending generosity
to other people and giving them an open
and safe space and someone doesn't
provide that then that's a pretty big deal
breaker for me.
I want the person that I'm going to
be in a relationship or whatever, um,
to be able to give me the independence.
It would someone who had like
low emotional intelligence.
If it was someone who that was way too
dependent on me and the relationship so
we can not complete one another,
but we can come together
and build each other up.
I think a big deal breaker for
me as someone who isn't honest,
if you're not Vegan, I don't want
to date you. I'm joking. I'm joking.
I'm Vegan, but that's not a deal
breaker, right? You're like, okay, God,
why did you say that?
But I love how you placed.
That's what's so special about you is
that you love to play it back about you.
Yes.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm going to hear it. Three.
Okay.
This is sound big,
but Kiani and the reason why is because
we're here to like have a relationship,
but I would love to be her friend.
I think she would be so dope as a friend.
Probably Jill as well.
Uh,
Victoria out. Oh God. Maybe
I do like Victoria. This,
this is,
you're pressuring me.
I mean, I'd love to keep traveling.
I love traveling overseas. Um,
but I also would like really
love to have a family someday.
So I guess those are two. What
do you mean by some day? Uh,
like have a family someday. Like,
well, how many years out do you think?
I'm probably in the next five,
whatever I'm doing,
I want to be helping people and I
know that when I'm helping people,
I'm proud of myself. Oh my gosh.
I just made my heart. Oh really?
Yeah. I'm currently a student. I'm
a third year Undergrad, so, um,
right now I'm studying education,
so my goal is to become a teacher one day.
It's, Oh gosh, uh,
I think I'm going to, hopefully I'm
right with my notes. I feel, I apologize,
but I'm going to go with,
with Liz.
God,
Hey.
I mean I've never been on a blind date,
like literally or Nice,
you know, so I'm a little, am I
a little, I mean a lot nervous.
I'm also really excited.
Would you like to see each other?
Do you want to see each other or do
you want to see each other later?
Like right now, right now. Hi Can we do,
we did that hog in the hug
was, I was like, oh my gosh.
It's a little awkward at first because
it's like so much at one moment. Ah,
this is exciting.
This is moving away now.
And then I'm moving back of
your socks by the way. Thanks.
And so I took a step back to
hopefully give her that space.
You could also show me the moves
that you have when it comes to, uh,
when it comes to a
climbing, climbing. Yes.
Hopefully after this weekend,
exchange contact information,
if she's down, of course,
it's all about if she's willing,
because I would love to,
to figure out if there is chemistry,
you know,
based on just conversing. So, yeah.